selon vous quel chroniqueur pourrait
pousser cyril dans les escaliers pour
prendre sa place dans tpm p attention
whore mathieu bien entendu puisqu'il
n'est pas là attention c'est parti tb mr
spock castaldi
qualité mais qui dit guy guy guy à fait
vrai
bajeux l'observent là depuis le début et
c'est vrai que sous ces petits their
chantait pas wes un petit sourire là je
ne sens pas totalement mais toi vous
pourrez mener les enquêtes toujours avec
les exercices auxquels bien sûr c'est un
traître dans l'âme et ils en rêvent
un traître dans la main c'est vrai vous
mettez guy roux aussi week end à louis
et kelly j'ai une grande confiance oui
exactement pareil
cette première historique entre une
conscience en vue on mène l enquête on
ne va pas on va pas le condamner
maintenant il faut mener l'enquêté
[ __ ] et monsieur jantes attention
attention pour le reste c'est beaucoup
de casse ta remarque
aussi bernard bernaoui parce que je le
trouve en même temps très bon dans le 6
et 7 donc il pourrait être légitime à
vouloir vous pousser à l'écriture il
serait dès samedi après bien entendu la
chaîne n'a pas encore en vie n'ait pas
permis
sciemment ou non oui aux frais jamais
mais c'est mal mais je n'avais c'est
vrai j'ai bien aimé puis j'aime bien en
tout cas ça sonne aussi casta est allié
sans foi ni loi c'est connu je pense
qu'il a tout pour ajouter quelque chose
à sa fiche wikipédia oui d'accord mais à
sa fiche de
questions
alors on va pas le faire selon vous quel
chroniqueur adot un peu trop hauts
plateaux il ralentit le rythme d'une
émission n est pas là mais ça veut dire
quoi ça rigolait vous pensez à qui vise
à magna isawi enfin pas le faire selon
vous quelle quelle époque quel est selon
vous le chroniqueur à l'hygiène la plus
limites by ap les limites a les
mêmes mettre un mec qui est pas là alors
atlantique où un mec qui est là voilà
alors guillaume à tort c'est terminé
merci
gilles verdez m'étais benji pas bien sûr
ils peuvent la gueule
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas vrai il veut pas souvent de
très près c'est pas vrai ça me faisait
pas vrai il plus des yeux mais pas de la
gare
si le scrutin qui plus des yeux vous et
me disent ah ah oui quoi il est je la
soupçonne de ne pas se démaquiller le
soir que revient le lendemain c'est le
même
c'est pas vrai était un non mais j'ai
raté mon enquête moi j'ai enquêté parce
que j'ai vu à la télé hier que j'étais
pas là d'air vous avez levé eux aussi
elle en disant bernard montiel genre
comme si j'étais décidée d'agréable à
écouter moi j'espérais
voilà je vous vois aujourd'hui revenir
au ressuscité mallory et donc j'ai vu
comme a été la télé hier et j'ai déjeuné
avec a aujourd'hui 7 à maquillage
d'accord donc elle est nickel alors même
si vous trouvez vous aussi non j'ai mis
dans l aléna non mais parce qu'il pète
tout le temps si
ce sont les pays bas et qui dit aussi
pareil cas star moi j'ai mis 15 star
parce que contrairement à mes autres
camarades que j'adore moi j'ai des
vraies infos gabon et le matin casta va
aux sports se prend pour un grand boxeur
en ce moment on se comprend par son
délire
et il arrive à l'émission directement
rentrant de la boxe nom n'était pas
couché battant avec des changes alors
vraie info c'est vrai que ça va changer
mon jeu
je vous réponds merci je peux répondre
mais ça n'est que le vendredi parce que
j'ai pas le temps entre la boxe si vous
allez attendre dit vous êtes salles
d'audience
papotent mentir si vous êtes fans
vendredi jean-paul quoi vous seriez pas
plu au bio
n'est pas moi qui ai mis casta déjà
l'avé sans déranger les gens n'en vous
je veux savoir quand il est en quartier
rien qu'à l'odeur
des méchants
attention delphine même pas fait
attention question selon vous quel
chroniqueur joue le mieux la comédie sap
à l'antenne mais tarbes en dehors
mais attention à ses dires sa pathologie
auquel on tient là
alors je sais pas ils cassent tout le
monde à l'extérieur le monde même vous
même vous et ça sent pas bien
mais qui vous jérémy grimm et j'assume
pas j'assume pas encore mais a
guidé
ses clients avec bio j'ai paniqué
nombreuses
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le chronomètre nous stresse
c'est comme ça beaucoup de gens me
gilles les mecs et madame non en vrai
moi j'ai mal compris la question parce
que moi je voulais dire que gilles il
est et ça c'est important de le dire
mille fois plus gentil en vrai avec le
rôle qu'il a à la télé ça rien compris
au
sahara tendent à le dire au ministre
ballon peine on punit oui oui donc c'est
le contraire en fait pourquoi vous avez
mis gilet pare balles
oui bah je sais pas aujourd'hui ta tête
et me revient pas je suis dans les
services que j'étais rendu à bloquer la
vente alors balesi pas la
peine d'essayer de rattraper non non non
non non ce
[Applaudissements]
qui me prend pour un concierge elles
vendent toutes sortes de cours à me
chercher un café va le chercher à darche
a dit là les vrais dossiers dites le
nous lui falloir aucunement confiance
non elle m'a déjà demandé non de l'ordre
de l'aider pour acheter des trucs pour
lui pour lui apporter les kenyans à
rigoler et bien cela que je sais que
guillaume est un temps laissé à laisser
l'appareil guillaume dit toute la vérité
sont si vous demandez un sac vous aurez
alors
coiffé d un sac shopping non non non ça
un jour j'ai commandé quelque chose sur
internet guillaume j'avais besoin d'un
sac on n'a pas confiance en vous ne
rêviez ou genton kevin me prends pour
son assistant clairement ray elle me
demande régulièrement d'aller lui
chercher des trucs donc ça a été évincé
il ya un dossier important
non mais oh vous savez maintenant où je
serai obligé de stopper notre
association
et ne regardez pas la regarder pas elle
va vous mettre un coup de pression comme
un défi tout à l'heure c'est bon allez
je suis extrêmement déçu de la réponse
de kelly oui j'ai l'image hand à
plusieurs reprises d'aller lui acheter
des vêtements et du livret sur site quoi
pour l'émission des vêtements des
italiens avec terrasse un truc je peux
arrêter non je vous jure c'est vrai mais
des cadeaux je la trouve
particulièrement ingrate ce soir
maintenant j'avais besoin de collants il
faisait les magasins il va alors il
acheter des colombes
[Rires]
et d'économie
gb ce serait complètement et elle va
faire rembourser les colons non mais de
l'avis non sur celle d'argent by c'était
quand c'était tranquille et rice alors
non mais non il paraît qu'il y a mais
yann
associés c'était comme ça c'était il ya
six mois mais ça qu'on soit ça c'est dit
oui bien sûr encore vérité va me
chercher une canaille un truc grave
accroc dit c'est de la pure gentillesse
si tu ne dit pas la vérité non j'ai
simplement été gentils les tonnelles
stanley gèreront cette absence cette
association c'est la vérité je ne vous
crois pas elles à l'arrêt il ya un gros
dos escale après monfils lui a bien
évidemment laver un truc elle a dû lui
demander de l'argent comme ça
s'est passé il ya un bail mais mais mais
là rien n'est joué mais l'officier a
référé avait sauvé des arrêtés ont
déconné c'est mon âme est repêché sam
abal justement à 9h30 on n'a aucune
confiance en vous sachiez
non mais elle et elle est devenue très
monteuse en plus sinon vous
selon vous quel chroniqueurs et le plus
léché qq de cyril
[Musique]
alors benjamin gille jhinaoui sa gueule
j'ai vraiment gilles benji alors j'ai
pourquoi gilles parce que lui doit des
1000 amis vous oui alors tu te fous de
moi ou quoi
pour moi c'est ça ton argument c'est
tout le toit dans le sens du patron
verra tous portent à lui brosser dans le
sens du poil tu fais dans ce sens de
personnes buts à rien à dire
pourquoi benjamin benjamin benjamin
parce que sans vous il n'existe pas et
oui sa grande faiblesse et pourquoi pas
prendre de but il n'a pas d'argent pas
d'ami pas de connaissance pas d'avenir
rien fait il pas celui qu'il faut je le
dis respectivement à bas mais j'ai le
cul ou [ __ ] voilà
et vous le savez très bien peser
longtemps c'est vrai que je le sais tu
as
d'altino 6ème et casta louis barthou
kenji alors j copié sur le gilet en fait
mon ami je l'espère vous c'est une vidéo
oui j'entends parce qu'ils arrêtent pas
dire qu'est ce qu'il est beau qu'est-ce
qu'il est bien habillé qu'est-ce qu'il
est brillant en fait oui mais tu le dit
trop en fait je lui dis en paddle qui
l'a jamais vu jouer au paddle en face à
na aucun sens si sa vue des devoirs des
vidéos oui on a tous répondu à la
question vous quelle est votre réponse à
cette question le plus lâche cul ouais
alors je vais vous dire je vous dis
je vous le dirai est-ce qu'il est là
d'abord où il est là à jouer l'europe en
chemise et pull c'est moi
c'est josiane
faire
le prix les secousses et guillaume
gille fait avant l'émission silva
djediat surpris en train de renifler
move est
c'est vrai qu'on voit des flammes ont pu
aller s'il vous plaît question selon
vous quel chroniqueur mériteraient
d'être mis en vacances pendant au moins
six mois moi je pouvais mettre même des
chroniqueurs qui ne sont pas là bien
entendu allez-y
merci à alors louis abitibien tous les
soirs et qui bientôt un jean noir à guy
guy guy guy louis guillaume becker et
delphine parce que en fait guillaume
tombe bien parce que tu sais qu'il ya un
adage qui dit loin des yeux loin du
coeur et je pense que si tu partais six
mois ci ne me voyais pas six mois ça
permettrait tu vois de faire ton deuil
de notre amour voilà c'est mieux pour
lui
vous allez remettre les vend toutes les
missions c'est là ça devient gênant
c'est le chaînon est non alors vous
allez me isabelle et valérie été suivis
parce que je sentais sale et de la demie
tôt
il assumer un peu on est tout le temps
là faut qu'elle se repose un petit peu
bannie pas là ce soir mais bref
d'ailleurs c'est delphine là c'est pas
isabelle
aubret montiel vous même oui eh bien
écoutez bas c'est bon
signe a vraiment aucun problème si moi
j'adorerais partir six mois quelque part
c'est vrai mais payer
et quand même par jonathan paquet signé
d'accord mais je vous explique si c'est
vous qui vous barrent est royalement que
vous payez allez vous dorer la pilule
aux maldives kaunas jeu mettra maladie
je m'assois maladie mauvezin qui est du
match aller vous chercher
des raisons d'être
tu rajoutes donner des raisons selon
vous quel chroniqueur est tellement nul
qui serait plus logique qu'ils donnent
de l'oseille à cyril pour être à
l'antenne
payés pour venir qui devraient payer par
devenir aller sur ses pas traîner s'il
vous plaît
saka star revient beaucoup
avec un stade c'est fort et les es moche
alors est ton ami casta et valérie welsh
maîtres
[Applaudissements]
castanet maintenant c'est bah dit bill
alors pourquoi casta et guillaume
vraiment regardé à droite pose pas les
bonnes questions
non mais dites pourquoi kelly or moi
j'irai l'éloquence quoi
ça ne va vraiment pas faites les nous
fussions way à l'étranger si vous allez
vous y allez donner le temps à l'état se
dégage sur les wii et wii
s'il vous plaît ça va l'académie
française après de faire fuir
ben j il vit sur son passé on peut pas
vivre éternellement sur le passé il n'a
ni présent ni avenir mais non tu n'es ce
pas conneries toinon fn
moi j'ai suivi le groupe à non non non
non non moi j'ai suivi le groupe c'est
l'effet de meute ça on l'a dit la vérité
gg fall fn m
pourquoi ce qui devrait vous donner
d'argent maintenant mais déjà il en a
pas beaucoup il va pas vous en donner en
plus mais à cours voilée
désorientés non j'ai subi groupe je
savais pas qui dira c'est vraiment
horrible cette question bah quoi voulez
vraiment vous voulez vraiment nous ont
pas du tout plutôt solide et ferid
d'ailleurs quelque part je paye pour
venir l'antenne t'envoie un calcul tout
que j'ai perdu comme aux ayants en loge
avec vous oui c'est un ring fortune faut
un vrai talent c'est vrai mais vous
voyez ceux d'en bas c'est comme ça les
chéris selon vous à quel chroniqueur
cyrine ne devrait-il jamais confier un
secret c'est à dire la plus grande
poucave celui à qui ralentit on devra
d'ailleurs moins confiance en fait un
cessionnaire qui vous avez moins
confiance autour de la table
camille cali mais c'est vrai
qu'elle y faisait mais vous même
c'est vrai qu'il avait serré que vous
êtes une rallonge
gardien pas les gouro les grosses crèche
les gammes non non non mais les petits
secrets mais je les bats l'ancien régime
et ses lions public en même temps m
guillaume dides être dingue sur vous et
moi j'en peux plus
je deviens sentimental des jantes en
tôle liste le 10 revient gentiment
travail j'aime bien tout le monde mais
n'a pas besoin de balancer sur séries
comme tu fais
à la boutique est liée aussi comme tout
le monde oui j'ai fait ça pour le public
sache erreur non mais vous allez vous
apercevoir
savez très bien montiel mais parce qu'
il aime bien les petits potins enfin je
crois que il aime bien les petits potins
les potins de stars et tout j'avais
compris le
mais peut-on alors regarde pas les
secrets et bernard il aime bien il aime
bien les petits pots talhaoui kelly et
comme tout le monde sait même pas que
j'ai suivi ces c'est un fait quoi ah oui
c'est vrai à quoi elle balance tout bas
même elle le dit oui la cession à la vie
je crois chez elle c'est son problème
mais non mais c'est vrai alors ne
fabriquait alors que moi les chéris
pouvait tout mot confiance
delphine est ce que je dis les secrets
dit la vérité pour l'instant non
et des
chiens se tiendront pas non mais pour
l'instant le nom d'emprunt c'est
l'émission n'est pas fini bon donc je
dirais loyal et secret sur un certains
d'entre nous bien sûr gros gros serrure
et je ne lis jamais dit par exemple
j'avais un secret que vous ne rêvez leur
est pas moi sur qui vous avez un secret
lavoir de la table 1 re tant
qu'investissement j'ai des secrets sur
planète j'ai des secrets turcs your way
est très gros secret mais moi aussi des
gros secret mais on les dit pas autre
chose les dix pas vous voulez dit en
tout cas j'ai des secrets sur des films
j'ai des secrets / / / / / castaldi
mais je ferme ma gueule
question
ah oui à chalon vous hélas cette
question elle est très dure selon vous
quel chroniqueur mériterait de prendre
définitivement les rênes du 6 à 7
alors là là là là alors moi je sais
je rappelle que ça tourne entre montiel
benhaim et castaldi en ce moment
alors
valérie pour vous géraldine c'est normal
bah oui l incroyable d'accord elle crève
l'écran monk montiel ouais je regardais
une étude à médiamétrie chiffres sont
sans appel à vous entre rires mais je
l'enseigné galeries de finale
bon ben c'est vous le meilleur castaldi
annonce des bonus annoncée bout
d'ailleurs maintenant j'ai dit pour qui
vous fait je dois avoir tout tout tout
l'argent l'argent tout l'argent que
beinheim bernard je trouve excellent et
benjamin il est vraiment l uvre est mort
vendredi vraiment
voilà qu'à ce jeu est très bon pour la
cohésion
enfin là les friends avec raymond isa
n'a pas brillé compris la question d'un
guillaume ne présente pas des noms mais
alors elle voudrait que sa chambre en
fait pour pas qu'ils aient des jaloux
guy soit il part en vacances pour
oublier et au moins c'est bien pour lui
soit il présente le 6 à 7 comme ça il ya
une satisfaction excusez moi vous croyez
qu'on va faire toute la vie de ces huit
ont fini son
voyage chez onet jeudi valérie chez moi
je n'ai encore regardé tout à l'heure
elle est parfaite un charme fou c'est
très agréable kelly ah bah moi j'aurais
mis j'aurais mis le blâme et valérie
excusez moi vous avez un trou noir
black out as well as car il s'est passé
un truc de fou mais je sais ben
laden interstellaire
didus monte
plus haut que trois planètes un pastiche
dans le système solaire que vous dire
puis tanus
film de riad dans la médina
[Applaudissements]
merci on vous rappelle valérie 1 valérie
au royaume des aveugles les borgnes sont
rois
c'est pourquoi je vous aime bien vous
avez toujours un petit mot gentil
c'est donc maintenant dernière question
à aa
avec qui vous ne partirai jamais en
vacances
en chroniqueur avec tout seul va jamais
parce que c'est une énorme tana ce qui
vous plaît c'est la dernière question la
personne ne peut ne pas être là où nous
peut être là mais disent la vérité
abusée l'envers alors il ya bois il ya
beaucoup qu'il a oui louis boyard pour
vous une île pourquoi ils ces infos
jeunes en fait tous les vieux dans sa
tête il écrit il est très très chiant
donc jamais kelly louis pourquoi le pot
à l étroit moureu les gens amoureux ses
champs ah ouais
oui ils évitent fragile non mais si j'ai
toujours eu des delphinidés remuant je
suis fan je suis fan de gilbert va j'ai
toujours voulu être ami avec lui mais ne
calcule pas et ne peut pas être amis
avec moi d'accord je ne surtout pas
delphine david gill ouais j'ai me gilles
aussi pourquoi
[Musique]
[Rires]
vide interstellaire
infiniment petit
plus tonus rends-toi
les planètes sont alignées
bienvenue dans le système interstellaire
ces radios qui vous parle
d'élection il ya beaucoup de gilles
verdez ils vous disent ah ouais je
n'aime ni la soutenir la purée
[Musique]
on va terminer sur cette méchanceté